we appreciate you being with us today on
the hill mayorcas wasn't just grilled
over the Border watch this exchange with
Senator Josh Holly take a look this is a
paraglider a Hamas
paraglider depicted here with a machine
gun flying into Israel she posted it
under her online Alias with the
celebratory free
Palestine Mr secretary what what's going
on here is this is this typical of of
people who work at DHS this is an asylum
and immigration officer who is posting
these frankly Pro genocidal
slogans and images on the day that
Israelis are being slaughtered in their
beds what have you done about this four
things I'd like to say to you number one
your question to suggest that that is
emblematic of the men and women of the
Department of Homeland Security is
Despicable I'm sorry what have you this
person works for the Department of
Homeland Security have you fired her
that was one of four answers have you
fired her one have you fired her don't
come to this hearing room when Israel
has been invaded and Jewish students are
barricaded in libraries in this country
and cannot be escorted out because they
are threatened for their lives you have
employees who are celebrating genocide
and you are saying it's despicable for
me to ask the
question here now Missouri senator Jos
Holly well did they fire her Senator I'd
like an answer did we ever find out they
did not fire her they did not fire her
that's the answer Sean is he finally
admitted that she's still on the payroll
after all of this she posts these images
celebrating the terrorism celebrating
Hamas boasting that she is an asylum
officer in our government and she's
still on the payroll the mayorcas has
lied to Congress repeatedly I thought it
was illegal to lie to Congress he has
told us again and again the border is
secure he has told us again and again
the border is closed at what point is he
held accountable and what should that
accountability be for lying to Congress
and lying to the American people he is a
liar yeah my view is Sean is that he
needs to be impeached I mean really I
think we have it has risen to the level
when you systematically disregard the
laws of this country when you
systematically mislead the American
people and lie as you said lie and lie
and lie to Congress and the American
people you're not doing your job and you
should be removed he's not going to
resign Joe Biden is not going to remove
him he is going to have to be removed by
the house and I think that that
proceeding should go forward if ever
there was a candidate for an impeachment
inquiry it would be mayorcas let me ask
you do you have any doubt among the 8
million people that Joe Biden has
allowed into this country illegally at
frankly not just allowed they have been
aiding and abetting in the law breaking
we had we had a system where the Border
was Secure and closed and policies that
were working under President Trump my
question is you know do do you do you
have any doubt in your heart or mind
because I have none that in fact among
the 8 million maybe 10 million by the
end of this year of these illegal
immigrants that people that have terror
ties are in this country plotting
planning scheming another 9911 or
Worse No Doubt whatsoever we know Sean
that there have been almost 170 people
on the terrorist watch list just this
last year who we've apprehended now
think about all the people who've Got
Away 170 an all-time record that's who
we know about now our border is not
secure and it is an invitation to every
terrorist out there to come across come
into this country they're not sending
any of the illegal aliens home Sean of
the of the millions who've come across
the border in the last few years 99 9%
of them are still in the country
99% so this is what you get with an open
border you get crazy people coming
across who want to hurt Jewish Americans
who want to kill all Americans who are
plotting
terrorists incidents and we're not going
to know until it's too late well let me
ask you this last question when you see
these numbers of people showing up now
on our border larger and larger numbers
from the Middle East specifically Iran
Syria but also China and also Russia and
I look at these numbers why are they
coming here Senator I don't have a good
feeling about
it well they're coming here because they
know The Border's open and they're
coming here because they don't like us
Sean I mean this is the thing that
worries me what you're getting at is
that we've got people flooding across
our border we've got members of the
Chinese Communist Party who are coming
into the country we've been warned that
folks who are are tied to Hamas are
coming in posing as Gaza refugees we
don't know who's coming in other than
that all kinds of folks who are
dangerous and it's open season and this
is a clear and present danger to the
American people great job today Senator
thank you for joining us tonight we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else